you know Netflix I got a little insight
into how Netflix works you want to talk
about a monster they're so global you're
talking about a thirteen billion dollar
budget thirteen billion dollar just for
just for like their sci-fi channel okay
oh but I told you I'd like to Whitney
about her special yeah and you know what
she had a she had a name originally for
the special but she met with the team at
Netflix and went there you don't
understand so in in our world Whitney or
name any comic you want Hannah Wilbur as
anybody they're big in our world in the
grand scheme of things they're not that
big so if you want to reach millions
upon millions people just the title
alone has to be catchy American boner
that was rushed on there certain titles
sure title was pretty safe there no no
so what's the title can I touch it even
if you're if you're not familiar with
Whitney you see can I touch it now stand
up that's [ __ ] hilarious I'll make
you a special American bone it would be
huge yeah that's the reason you do that
stuff
so there's they're saying like even I
forget the comic but he had a thing
where it was just him like this and that
the title was real small but he was big
not too many people clicked on it now
they switch it where the titles huge and
he's a Mike like 60% more people click
that yeah they don't know who he is but
they are just looking for comedy yeah
they have crazy web the average the
episode cost nine million dollars for
like just say let's there sci-fi channel
nine million in episode it used to be a
million dollars in episode was like
crazy so stranger things it's something
like ten million dollars in episode yeah
it's like a mini movie right which is so
[ __ ] nuts pretty much money I got
stranger things
oh it's it's it's crazy but they have an
ability to where they can um they can
see so they would they have to find a
location where they want to shoot it
they put it into a algorithm it's like
this is how much it cost shooting
Bulgaria Simon's cousin Romeo they have
it and then they have actors there like
they can your you're a number now you're
an actor this is these are the actors
that can get a certain number of views
it's all becoming so you know even in
comedy though they can go okay well if
they if you say hey of this hour what do
you think of it thing all right well we
know no matter who
with its Chris Rock bill burr or the
small guy on the totem pole people
watched about 23 minutes then so it has
to be [ __ ] 5 so you're closer that
you're saving at the very end yeah you
should probably put in the front yeah
most people aren't gonna make it that
far if they do they'll watch it in
blocks yeah
the chopping it up so it's crazy to me
so and by the way in a lot of ways
Hollywood has kind of lost its relevance
financially and they don't even know it
yet I mean the world the global market
is so much bigger now it's so big that
Hollywood is like the day of the movie
star dramas where you put like chewy
shhhhh it really doesn't exist anymore
well everyone has their own like fanbase
everything's very neat you're not even
making dramas anymore it's like dramas
are not really what they used to be you
just don't do it oh this guy Nate
bargatze he's gonna do our special he's
great
I mean he sent ones like yeah he's great
he's a big natural community monster
great super monster brave best special
on Netflix oh my gosh yeah I told my
monster behind me but um Fury's going
with oh I Christina you know Tom's wife
Christina yeah
Pete she we were basically neighbors but
I saw her at Whole Foods and I demon
reckon I saw she had some cool tie-dyed
pants on some like D'Elia would wear
that caught my attention but her kid man
they have a one and a half year old it
looks identical to Tom he's a girl
but this this guy um said this thing
this kid is so [ __ ] cute that's what
I didn't mean I didn't realize even for
a second I was waiting to get some meat
at the the counter and I see this kid
come by and post a little head out from
his mom I was like good god that's a
Gerber baby oh my kids cutest [ __ ] they
Christina goes Tom like oh [ __ ] like he
looks like uncle to Tom she was it's a
shame in it she's so funny she's great
but there dude they don't post picture
their kid I don't think but god damn
this kid is cute man yeah a little
Gerber baby a little Gerber baby god it
was cute I reminded me of something and
I camera what the hell it was yeah they
don't post pictures of their kid oh yeah
some kids up top I'm not sure where they
are
that's Ali wonks here that's them in the
pool with those crazy hats on fantastic
yeah super cute though
yeah that kid I mean I'd even realize
Christina the kids so goddamn cute blind
and cute some peers one thing is how I'm
gonna get my American boner on Netflix
my next special American boat oh
absolutely crush because we we always
over like all my fan fan base well you
people gonna watch you got to hit the
math if the masses are funny titles
that's [ __ ] it meet all the fans all
of us here all the fans are saying like
please do that title actual [ __ ] caught
American Bowl it was the best idea of
yeah right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]